you may think the greatest most
perplexing mysteries of the universe
exists way way out there at the edge of
a black hole or inside an exploding star
but some of them surround us all the
time I can show you in this container
we're gonna catch some super fast
subatomic particles that are raining
down on us from space
they're called cosmic rays and exactly
where some of them come from it's a part
of this hundred-year-old mystery in
physics cosmic rays are a form of
radiation Ray's is a misnomer they're
actually little bits of atoms whizzing
by us even through us all the time every
square centimeter of the earth at sea
level including the space at the very
top of your head gets hit by one of
these particles every minute we can't
feel them
and they don't cause our bodies any harm
but they can sometimes do weird things
like make computers malfunction by
messing with their memory scientists
have been studying cosmic rays since the
early 1900s when a physicist went up in
a hot-air balloon
and discovered the radiation increases
the higher you go meaning that it comes
from somewhere in space since then we
found out ways to make these little bits
of atoms visible like we're gonna do
here we built something called a cloud
chamber up here is felt that we've
soaked with a super concentrated
solution of rubbing alcohol and at the
bottom here is dry ice which is super
cold so when the alcohol vapor goes down
to the bottom and gets really cold it
condenses and forms a cloud and then
when cosmic rays come shooting in from
space the alcohol vapor forms into
little droplets and you can actually
trace their path through the cloud
hopefully
wait wait I saw one yeah yeah the
particles inter cloud chamber are
traveling from space at nearly the speed
of light as are the untold others
passing by you and through you right now
when they hit the top of our atmosphere
the impact is so powerful that the atoms
of radiation burst open tearing apart in
violent cascading collisions that's what
we see in the cloud chamber atomic
shrapnel that has reached the ground
scientists have determined that some of
these rays come from the sun's
atmosphere and the former solar wind and
others from exploding stars but the most
powerful rays are the most puzzling they
don't even come from our own galaxy they
come from some unknown source on the
universe the energy from the very most
powerful ray recorded enough power to
turn on a light bulb for a second or
more that force is comparable to a top
tennis pro hitting a ball with all their
strength doesn't sound that impressive
but think of this all of that energy is
squeezed into an area smaller than an
atom to try to figure out what entity
could be shooting these incredibly
powerful Ray's in us scientists use
massive cosmic ray observatories with
detectors not too different from our
cloud chamber well you know there are a
higher budget there they're more
advanced one in the South Pole uses a
gigantic block of ice whole cubic
kilometer to track the Rays instead of
vapour another one in Argentina has 1600
huge water tank spread out over a
thousand square miles but instead of
just observing cosmic rays is issued by
scientists use sophisticated technology
to trace the atomic shrapnel backwards
there they can reconstruct the original
cosmic ray that hit the top of the
atmosphere but confirming their source
in the deep reaches of space isn't so
easy because these cosmic rays don't
always travel in a straight line instead
the various magnetic fields of the
universe and the galaxies put them on
bendy paths so are there any ideas where
they come from scientists have a few
suggestions the cosmic rays could be
created in the violent hearts of
galaxies far away another leading
hypothesis is that they're not produced
by exploding stars per se but by
bouncing around in the shockwaves
produced by those explosions
there's also the possibility that some
of the Rays are produced by forces and
objects we don't know about or interact
with things like dark matter in ways
that we don't yet understand where they
could come from strange objects left
over from the Big Bang
I mean aliens could be shooting these
things at us but I doubt it what
scientists need is more data more
observations to be able to pinpoint the
sources in the sky these particles are
coming from there scientists can figure
out where the most powerful cosmic rays
come from a means that are discovering
one of the most powerful things the
entire universe perhaps the most
powerful thing in the entire universe
that might open up an entirely new
branch of physics teaching us about how
the universe is formed and about how
matter could be pushed to the extreme
but until their origin is discovered we
can think of cosmic rays as these
messengers from the broader universe a
reminder that were part of it and that
there's still a great deal of mystery
out there
[Music]
you
[Music]